good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and
happy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday everybody's looking forward to
the weekend weekend Friday Frid getting
down on
Friday beautiful per
usual per usual wouldn't expect anything
less for my swirly you look gorgeous
just me no yeah I feel like you've been
really wearing your hair up a lot and
it's down and you're just looking
gorgeous radiant Beyonce like I wear my
hair up like two times a week probably
cuz it's just the cycle of things like
today I washed my hair last night so I
have fresh blown out hair by me today
but yesterday and the day before it was
like dirty hair so it was making its way
into a bun understand so Friday fresh
usually I hold out I don't wash my hair
till Friday night which I could have
gone one more day but I wanted my hair
done for the weekend and I know that if
I wash it on a Friday night I'm never
going to do it this weekend but I have
to do it for the toast so now I have my
hair done yeah I've recently discovered
the underrated style of a flat iron like
I feel like for so long I was doing the
most like full blowouts curling like no
flat iron like enough yeah I actually
just started cuz now when I go to sleep
with my hair wet which I always do it's
still wet in the morning but it's
actually serving me cuz now I use my
Dyson like a blow dryer and I'm able to
achieve like a faux blowout which
blowout which I wasn't able to achieve
before she's over here achieving things
ladies and gentlemen achieving my goals
and my dreams and I just feel like
you've just have like a list of
achievements and you're checking them
off yeah so I've achieved this nice hair
luk and that's my story yeah so it's
just like day two of me telling you you
look beautiful and getting nothing in
return oh okay but sometimes can it be
like that sometimes s cuz I'm always
showering you with compliments law she
in a row I don't know I know it's a lot
for you but I'm always showering you
with compliments law and I feel like if
I just like give you a compliment cuz
you gave me one phony baloney yeah it's
phony but it's also just you know
courteous like oh you look nice too
turty bony bogna it's CT courtesy a
courtesy if you will bogna
courtesy you look gorgeous wow so
sincere thanks we have such a big show
all the things we forgot [__] off this
week will happen today do not let us end
the show well depends the Kurds dictate
because you know we just got so off
track like really yesterday who the [__]
needed real houses Beverly Hills recap
not I not I we will attempt to get a
Beverly Hills recap in for this episode
and deer toasters from Wednesday yeah
the stories I guess I could Breeze
through them like I could wax potic we
don't have to Breeze or I could Breeze I
mean we have
we have
our time constraints given to us by the
Kurds we can't just go on forever plus
we have to like upload the episode I
just feel like the the sort of
structural and you
know segmental boundaries put on us by
ourselves you know by the Kurds no no no
by like all these things we just have to
do I think it definitely stunts
creativity I dis agree on about that I
think it sometimes it might feel like
it's stuning creativity but the larger
goal and the larger aim of those
boundaries like keep the show in check
what boundaries are you talking about
Fast Five Oh no I wasn't talking about
that I was talking about like TV recap
and dear toasters I mean we we don't
even do TV recap anymore this will be
our first TV recap in like six months I
feel like we're just like slowly talking
ourselves out of doing the things we
said we were going to do I mean I'm
really down like I we can maybe we just
tabularasa you know no no I'm fine not
recapping Beverly Hills so I did wind up
finishing it last night like it was bad
I have I really like I don't have
anything to say let's go really quick
okay do the way yeah like first of all I
really don't have that many thoughts on
real house house Beverly Hills my
thoughts and something I wanted to talk
about was Watch What Happens Live um the
guests were Kyle umansky and Kyle
umansky that was weird yeah like that
would be the
wrong Kyle Richards and Teddy mamp Andy
like grilled Kyle on Mauricio stuff and
the takeaways were that she had just
seen the photos of Mauricio and his
dance partner holding hands she was
really upset about it she had no idea
she was the one who initiated the
divorce so I don't know why she would be
mad about him cozying up with his
partner they're still living in the same
house separate bedrooms She took a guest
bedroom and let him stay in their
original bedroom um but the real reason
I wanted to talk about watch Rappin live
is because Teddy melan Camp was a guest
and honestly Andy Cohen just shouldn't
have invited her because he [__]
hates her oh my god I've never seen
someone have like such obvious contempt
for another human being every time Teddy
talked and like Teddy was being a little
cringe she kept trying to have like
moments and like say kind of like slay
worthy things being like I think Vicki
should look over here before she does
that like just really kind of trying
really hard like pre-rehearsed I
understand I understand and it was
giving cringe but like my God Andy this
person's on your show they guest of
yours like be a little cous Jackie he
was staring at her like she literally
had like a swastika on her forehead like
he just like hated her and I was like
this is so obvious my God pretend a
little bit I actually I felt bad for
Teddy why did he invite her on the show
I don't know that's weird and they did
like a whole segment like Teddy since
you're now like a Housewives podcast or
like let's go around the franchises and
get your takes on things and she was
again was giving like cringe like
pre-rehearsed just cringy onliners and
Andy wouldn't even respond he just gave
her like this Grimace and then moved on
to the next question I was so
uncomfortable watching it did anybody
else have that takeaway I can't be the
the only person it was so obvious that's
so funny I watched a little bit of Watch
What Happens Live last night because
Southern Charm was on my fave and
interesting
Duo who was it Kristen Stewart oh I saw
this and who was the other guest Janna
Kramer yeah I saw that too and I thought
that the booker at Watch What Happens
Live clearly made a mistake it was drunk
yeah Kristen Stewart is the type of
guest who would go one-on-one no no
maybe she didn't want that though she's
no she wouldn't go one-on-one especially
I don't think like Andy is like a Twi
hard and I don't think she wants to
spend the whole time talking about
Twilight herself of course but to have
like Jan they should have had like a
housewife that would have been funny
like or Shep but the few minutes that I
watched Jan and Kristen were really
getting along Jan thieves like Janna was
so like enamored with Kristen and
Kristen really appreciated it like they
had a nice Dynamic Janna was like you're
so sweet and you're so lovely and Chris
was like wow thank you like
it was an unlikely friendship right
that's what happens when you know a
mixed bag some sometimes things can
happen also Kristen Stewart I don't know
her you know personally and I I have
don't have her figured out and I haven't
really attempted to but she she's
definitely a mystery but right she's an
enigma but she's not the right guest for
Watch What Happens live because she
takes like so much time to answer stuff
and there's a lot of like you know
stuttering and that just so Bella you
Andy hates that like it's supposed to be
rapid fire and she's like oh well you
you know it was and you can't be
thoughtful or longwinded on Watch What
Happens Live you have 10 seconds to say
your peace and that's it yeah it so much
so that I think that they give people
the questions before just so that we can
move things along yeah that's they
should because there's so many time
constraints and Andy has no time for
anybody she was being like super Bella
like you know yeah yeah well starting
stopping and you just know Andy's like
we have to cut to commercial but Edward
said yeah she's like so stuttery so I
don't know if that's like Christen
brought that to the role of Bella or
Bella influenced Kristen Kristen brought
that to the role of Bella it was too
good of acting yeah and she does it in
her personal life was she licking her
lips a lot Bella was always licking her
lips and like biting her own lips
like ooh I I didn't notice but there was
like a lot of hand movements a lot of
like you know Crouch over sitting 's a
very theatrical type of girl but I like
I liked her and I love Twilight and it
was hard because you know that we just
want to talk about Twilight the whole
time and you know she's not about that
no and it's so crazy because she's the
type of person who obviously got so
famous off of this one franchise but
still has a myriad of accomplishments
she's not just really known for doing
one thing but it's really like the only
thing I want to talk about yeah and I
feel like you know some other people
from franchises don't do much afterwards
and even they don't want to talk about
the franchise but it's like what else
are we supposed to talk about to we
could talk about a thousand things but
we really only want to talk about
Twilight and our Pats for sure what else
can we talk about she was Diana she's
like an a DI she's a face of Chanel like
she's always doing movies like she has
stuff okay okay she has stuff she's
always in
Venice that's true and she was in Snow
White and the Huntsman like she's a
booked and busy girly yeah by the way
she's also another type like doing a
Disney movie that is the opposite of
what you stand for like she's so not
Disney you mean Snow White and the
Huntsman yeah but that was like edgy
plus I think she like the
director yeah I think they had a a fling
I think they flung they flung that was a
good movie so then real house of Beverly
Hills I agree with you really requires
absolutely no recapping the big moments
for me were the last two minutes with
Kyla Mauricio D going brunette which
everyone seems to be clowning on and I
actually really like it uh I miss her
blonde hair and I guess Erica saying
that thing about Doran PK at Bravo and D
being mad about it rightfully mad that
was shady but I also I thought Eric
actually gave a good as good of an
explanation as one could give like I'm a
showman and I gave them a show I
completely agree like it was shady and
then when she explained that like she
asked not to answer the question but
then she's on the stage people started
booing her so she gave them something
that people you know the Bravo fans
they're like they're uh what's feing for
drama yeah so she gave them exactly what
they wanted I kind of understood her
response too I understand D not
understanding it and still being mad and
just wanting more of an apology but this
a really like a dumb conversation yeah I
agree what was shocking to me is how
fractured the group is I feel like for
so long it was like the franchise where
they're they hung out all the time off
season you know the Fab Five was going
always going to dinner but it's like all
of these women haven't seen each other
since the reunion they literally needed
an eagle woman to repair them yeah that
was shocking too I think it's because
that fab five included Lisa Rena Lisa
Rena and Erica are so tight and a lot of
the fight from last year was between
Lisa Rena and Kyle so I'm sure Erica
took Lisa Ren aside Kyle and darit are
like beefing are they beefing yeah like
I'm watching What Happens Live um they
weren't beefing in the episode they had
that conversation that was so weird
about their relationships oh yeah oh no
in the in the trailer it's like DQ gets
mad that's that Kyle defends Sutton more
or something okay also where was crystal
hash where in the world is Crystal Kung
Minkoff was she on the retreat she
wasn't even in the episode are you sure
yeah oh oh and I didn't even notice it
until somebody tweeted I'm like oh my
God yeah where was she are you sure she
wasn't on the retreat I'm positive I
feel like she could have been there she
was not okay and then we had that weird
scene with garcel and her sons that felt
like so deeply intimate and beyond weird
to be sharing on TV so weird to like
bring your sons on camera to tell you
that you're a bad mom like yeah and
honestly I'm sure garcel was a great mom
yeah but why would she okay if she needs
to have that conversation with her her
sons like go and have it private why do
you want us to see that like I'm my my
heart was hurting no I know I felt
really bad for garel I felt really bad
for her and the sun just like kept
digging in almost like he was told like
up on camera like yeah it was very weird
to me it was so personal yeah I thought
it was weird the last couple of minutes
were very interesting it was the first
time we've really seen like a very clear
shift in Mauricio and Kyle's
relationship like they're demeanor how
they talk to each other strangers
they're strangers there's so much
tension like the tattoo thing is so
stupid it is weird he didn't know how
many tattoos she had yeah but she's just
like being like a a completely different
person even in her conf even in her
interviews like the way that she's
talking like just the intonations and
the speed at which she is just a
different person it's very
subdued she like a personality
transplant I completely agree but it's
interesting cuz in the confessionals for
the first episode it's clear that she's
still um maintaining like she hasn't
admitted yet that like there's something
wrong she's maintaining she's like you
know marriage highs lows you know it's a
bump so it's clear that maybe in the
beginning they were going to try and
like fix it and pretend and not put it
on camera but it's so far gone it's so
far gone so it wasn't like a great
episode but we've got to start somewhere
yeah oh what something actually
interesting that was very quickly talked
about was Kyle having a lot of animosity
for Sutton and I think Crystal for
remaining really friendly with Kathy and
like you know Kyle said I mean Sutton
loves a party and you know who throws a
better party than Kathy Hilton and then
there was all those pictures of them
hanging out I thought that was
interesting Crystal and Kathy are
friends before yeah and Sutton and Kathy
would be friends they would be they're
very similar but s Sutton knows Kathy
through
Kyle yeah I mean it's not that weird to
me like Kathy and KY could make up
tomorrow and then what everybody just
like gets on board again it's friends
with her like Kyle and S aren't that
close and Chris no they are they are oh
I guess Kyle and
Sutton Kyle has a legitimate gripe with
Sutton I think I just don't care I just
don't care and I think a lot of us
like would still want to be friends with
Kathy Hilton like I get it like not not
even out of thirst she seems like a
fabulous gal yeah no I I go be friends
just I'm not in the stage of caring
about the season yet hope yeah they
didn't they didn't pull me in no oh I
was of course really bothered by a lot
of the conversation about Eric's weight
loss they did on Watch What Happens live
too of course Andy had to ask and Teddy
actually gave a good
answer until she like undid her own
answer he was like what do you think
about the OIC allegations and teddy as
an accountability coach and a weight
loss person and she was like I just
think like we're so beyond the point of
commenting on people's bodies and their
weight loss and I was like oh great
answer then she's like but it's more
than just hormones I'm like you
literally just did what you said people
should stop doing yeah no leave AR alone
leave AR alone what kind of
hormones yeah I have heard that like
when you go to a doctor or like a med
spa for semaglutide there are a bunch of
other shots injections peptides hormones
that you can pair with it that make the
process like just to take care of your
body there's like fat burning I have
heard okay cool yeah we got to we got to
go see one of those just write that down
yeah so I don't think she's
lying
yeah I don't care yeah such a good
response that's kind of the overall
message for your recap of real housewi
at Beverly Hills I hope you all enjoyed
it we don't care and just like one
minute on Southern Charm if I may
because like my comfort show I watch
every week and I always forget to share
my thoughts not my favorite season but I
love these Peeps and I will say like I'm
struggling because last night there was
like a fight between Taylor Madison and
CHP and they were all a little bit right
and a little bit wrong and I don't know
whose side that I'm on like Taylor's
obviously wrong for you know engaging
in relations with a few people around
the table but she's admitted she said
I'm going through a hard time like I'm
making why is she wrong so she dated
Shep years broke up with her and broke
with on her and yeah and then she kissed
Austin but Olivia is her best friend and
Olivia has been like crying on her
shoulder about Austin turns out like
Taylor and him like talked about dating
and she lied to Olivia about it for
months not cool and then she send
Whitney a nude
photo we need to talk about Whitney so
so the thing I like about Taylor is like
when people you think like everyone's
talking about her she's going to get
like red in the face oh my God I can't
believe I did those things she's going
to try and lie and we s her way out of
it she's like with the Austin thing
she's just like I'm I like she's so hard
on her like she feels so bad it's like a
good person who made a mistake and it's
like nobody feels worse than she does
that she Li and she keeps being like I
lied to my best friend's face like how
can I she's just accepting that she did
wrong so I I you can't really fault her
too much and then the Whitney thing that
was like weird but she then she was just
like she took a new approach she's just
like I like the naked body I would walk
around naked if I could it's not a big
deal and and then the other the other
girls are like making fun of her cuz
they're like she's a bobble Thumper like
she doesn't practice what she preaches
and I'm like I'm not getting that sense
like okay she loves the Bible and she
sends nude pics get you a girl who can
do both she said Jesus wouldn't
mind and that's on so she's taking like
a fresh approach and every time she's
confronted about something I'm like not
mad at her okay I can respect that
approach like she's like not being shady
about she's being like very upfront
except that she lied to Olivia because
she like really didn't want to hurt her
she didn't realize like lying is so much
worse than just being honest then so
Madison's like going in on Taylor about
this like nude picture and she's like
going in on her on Olivia's behalf and
Olivia's like me and Taylor need to work
this out like please don't and I love
Madison and I just don't know why she's
like making this her problem right and
then Shep starts defend Taylor to
Madison and it's like Shep you're the
reason for if you would just like marry
the girl none of this would have
happened
right interesting so I'm a little mad at
everyone but I also like everyone I
think it's a pretty good place to be
yeah we'll see we'll see what happens
next should we dive in yeah I guess why
not what else is there you know it's
that's all there
is it's Friday we're going to let you
embark on your weekend but before we do
you have to know the fast stories that
you have to know and the fast five
stories that you have to know are
brought to you by Pillsbury your week
night dinner rotation just got so much
more tasty with the pillsberry crescent
rolls and the delicious simple recipes
that you can make with them so if you're
a busy mom busy student just a busy
person and you don't have time to whip
up like a Ratatouille every evening just
make sure to always have Pillsbury
crescent rolls stocked locked and loaded
in your kitchen because you can make
fabulous different recipes
uh that they have available on their
website so it's so easy I love add a
little tomato sauce a little cheese boom
you got a pizza so if you have a picky
eater like myself there's so many
different things you can just stuff in
there roll them up and make something
really really delicious so the week
night recipes are as easy as fill roll
and bake roll up your favorite
ingredients into a crescent roll and you
can have a quick and easy spin on a week
night recipe so their recipes that are
on pillsbury.com can be a pepperoni
pizza roll crescent you could also just
get rid of the pepperoni if you're a
kosher Girl Like Us chicken bacon ranch
crescent roll and the ham and cheese
crescent rolls but also like whatever
your Vibe is like I don't think enough
people talk about putting peanut butter
and jelly in a crescent roll boom you've
got a sandwich two delicious so you can
find Pillsbury in the dairy aisle you
you'll have dinner prep in 30 minutes or
less and most importantly for the picky
eater in your life whether they be an
adult or a child you know I'm speaking
from experience but I know a lot of
children are picky eaters as well you
can get dinner done in less than 30
minutes and it's pleasing to the picky
eater in your life so find pillsberry in
the dairy aisle and also check out their
recipe recipes on pillsbury.com for you
know inspiration but at the end of the
day no matter what you put inside it
it's good today's episode is also
brought to you by Quint we love high-end
luxury goods as much as an ex person but
our wallets aren't always on the same
page that was until we found Quint or
go-to place for luxury Essentials at
prices Within Reach quins creates
Timeless Classics that never go out of
style you'll have them in your closet
forever their capsule wardrobe must
haves like 100% Mongolian cashmere
sweaters from $50 washable silk tops and
dresses and flattering pants make
putting together an outfit that much
easier the best part of Quint is that
all items are priced 50 to 80% less than
similar Brands because they partner with
direct directly with top Factories at
Quint and they cut the cost of the
middleman and pass the savings on to you
so Quint only works with factories that
use safe ethical and responsible
manufacturing practices and premium
fabrics and finishes some could say one
could say that at Quint they use top
quality fabric top quality
fabric um so if you want affordable
luxury head to Quint I have so many
great pieces from Quint that I've worn a
million times a million different ways
they're very simple but they're really
well wellmade I have a cashmir sweater I
have a great pair of black slacks like
really good basic wardrobe Capsule
that's what they call it um items that
you can wear a ton of different times
and invest in really good pieces so get
affordable luxury with Quin go to
quinn.com toast for free shipping on
your order and 365 day returns that's qu
nc.com toast to get free shipping and 3
65-day returns quinn.com toast today's
episode is also brought to you by State
Farm it's tury from state farm you guys
and the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create a plan that gives you
options what that's funny tury from
State Farm I'm Jakey from State Farm
yeah you are the State Farm personal
price plan helps you create a plan that
gives you options so you get an
affordable price and it comes with a lot
of benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you because after all life is just
better when you can personalize your
experiences think about it like this
what are your music playlists podcast
feeds and social media Scrolls all have
in common well spoiler alert there a
reflection of you so we all know my
music playlist these days is giving
Taylor's version Jackie is probably
giving wheeles on the bus if I had to
guess no fors Harry's favorite song
Wheels yeah wheels and that's what the
State Farm P personal price plan has in
common it gives you options to help you
personalize your coverage so that you
can protect what you care about most all
at an affordable price just for you so
you'll be seeing more of yourself in
everything you love and I don't think
there's anything more beautiful than
looking around this world and seeing
yourself in everything you know and as
they stay as as they say at State Farm
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary and you know what
you can trust Jake from State Farm you
could trust Jakey from State Farm and
you can trust tury from State Farm you
can like a good neighbor stay f is there
our first Story Taylor Swift reaches
billionaire status with Eros tour
success so today's a big day for Taylor
one she's a billionaire two 1989
Taylor's version is out which kind of
snuck up on us like I didn't realize it
was coming out today did you remember it
was today I did know but only because
like a few days ago I remembered oh I
remember right and I have a couple
thoughts first of all just something
that was frustrating to me was that I
went to listen to the album this morning
and I knew that Kendrick Lamar like
redid bad blood but I didn't see it on
the album so I was like maybe I'm just
missing it and then it was like oh
there's a Delux there's 1989 Taylor's
version Deluxe and it's like the only
additional song why are there two
different like why can't we just have
one with all the goods explain the thing
about Miss Taylor is that she's going to
release four different versions of the
Same album four different versions I
have to assume it has to do with like
tracking and sales there's a reason for
it like a strategic reason I don't know
exactly what it is but I agree it's
annoying but like I would think you know
I wouldn't want someone to listen to Bad
Blood on this album Bad Blood on that
album all the streams on all the streams
in one it has to do with something I'm
not I'm not sure I'm I'm sure there's a
reason for it if you know please explain
in the comments cuz it was like it's
really annoying and then two I was
realizing that I actually feel like her
behavior in the last few weeks has been
very 1989 of coded and I don't know if
it's intentional but she's also like
dating the guy on the football team
she's with all her friends girl gangs
dinners Etc and that's what she was
doing when 1989 came out yeah she's
definitely been in her 1989 era and for
a lot of people that was their favorite
tailor specific era in terms of like
social media outfits friendships award
shows um I listen to the album I have a
lot of thoughts on the Vault songs I
still need to I've only listened to them
like twice through like give me a minute
they don't sound how I thought they'd
sound they sound very midnight I feel
like a lot of her current inspo was SA
was like influenced on this music but I
was really hoping for me 1989 is the
greatest pop album of all time and the
1989 tour should be studied by by
historians and there are so many things
in the 1989 live tour that are
magic Out of the Woods her rendition of
her own song out of the woods where I
think she makes it literally into a
better song is spectacular her uh mashup
of Enchanted and Wildest Dreams is one
of the most beautiful things I've ever
heard in my life I also really really
like the sco we are never getting we are
never getting back together version she
did a bunch of different spins on the
song and I would have loved loved if we
got either live versions of them or she
re-recorded the you know an out of the
woods you know different version yeah I
agree with I would have loved that I
agree and I
also this morning upon listening to the
album I didn't even make it to the Vault
tracks cuz I was just enjoying listening
to the album like it's the best album
period and it's it's like a basic answer
when people are like what's your
favorite Tor album CU it was like her
most like commercially successful album
at the time cuz it was technically her
first pop album even though like red is
really Pop um and it's just so good and
it's a delight to like go back and
because when it came out like my issue
with speak now is like it brings me back
to when I was 18 like I just can't
relate but this album I was like
22 Yeah I was 21 and it's a good time
it's a good time like I had a boyfriend
I was like getting famous on Instagram
like 1989 the year the 1989 years were
good years yeah like I was graduated
from college so I was like becoming an
adult and I just feel more connected to
that version of me than like and I said
speak now yes agreed
um what else did I want to say oh and
another thing she could have included on
like my dream Taylor's version for 1989
is
Sydney I'm I'm not that close to it
what's that oh did you ever see the
1989 movie DVD I don't think so where
can I watch it well you like can't I
mean it's on YouTube if you want to
watch it somebody like uploaded it you
get ads it's so annoying but it was an
apple music exclusive and the person who
updated it like wanted to give everyone
who watched it epilepsy it they do not
stay on one frame for more than two
seconds it is impossible to watch it's
infuriating to watch crowd close-up
backup dancer lights Sky crowd insan
it's so annoying and wait what was the
point I was trying to make
Sydney oh yeah so the town that she
filmed for 1989 and the one that the
concert that ended up being used for the
concert movie was in Sydney Australia so
she did this at other shows but the one
that people know from the DVD is Sydney
is I can't even explain it she just like
talks to the crowd and during um Blank
Space right before the bridge boy only
want love but before that she goes
Sydney and then they take that vocal and
it becomes a part of the background so
the whole time she's like
Sydney Sydney and so like swifties can't
call someone Sydney it's
Sydney wow okay I'm just not that close
to it but the bridge of Blank Space she
does like a a Harmony Echo so she'll she
does the boys only want love if it's
torture don't say I didn't say I didn't
warn you she does that three times she
does it the first time then it plays
back and she harmonizes with it again
then those two harmonies play together
and she harmonizes it with the third one
it's so good it's called a loop I think
cool yeah I could try and do the
harmonies right now if you wanted me to
if you think that you can and that would
be a pleasant audio experience you know
I'm always try so the first one is just
the regular boys only want love if it's
torture don't say I didn't say I didn't
warn you boys only want love if it's
warn you I did it very good oh my God if
somebody's like an audio editor can they
take all three of them SP them up and
lay them on top of each other Looper oh
my God sick maybe good that was really
good I didn't know what you were going
to take us I've watched it 1,000 times I
don't know how to naturally Harmon
harmonize like a lot of people hear a
song and can jump in and harmonize I
think people know that we don't know how
to harmonize and we'll never stop trying
but unless I can memorize the harmony
like I have then it's just another song
to memorize right right I if I could
harmonize I would be the most annoying
person on the planet it is a gift from
God to everyone else in the world that I
don't know how to harmonize no but
harmonizing is so beautiful my friend
Abe harmonizes and like I always make
him harmonize with me I'm like I'll sing
the melody you harmonize it's so pretty
damn you need to learn isn't it just
innate I think you can
learn okay okay I'll try and learn but I
agree like you either have it or you
don't yeah and like I have other things
like you don't get everything and of
course I could sit here and lament like
why didn't I get harmonizing why did I
get a good voice I got good handwriting
you know it's so true we all are given a
a hand of cards and you have the
handwriting one yeah and and I will say
I don't have the handwriting one and it
definitely sucks like yeah to not have
good handwriting I'm sure and I have
other cards I'm just can't think of them
right now I have them style I have style
you never go out of style so true I
think I take that one for granted for
sure that like I know how to that I know
how to get dressed yeah I also you're
just like naming things and I don't have
any of them I don't have good style you
don't have bad style though no but I
don't have like an eye okay but you have
what do I have you have comedy through
the nose okay I just feel like we're
always saying like no I'm going to keep
going I'm going to keep going you have
like magnetism L turd but that's like
that's what we always say that's so I
need to find and also I need to find
like skills not just okay things that
you are skillful at singing
yeah that's such a big card it is it is
it is it is but like it's not like a you
know
it's not as good as
handwriting you're also really good at
doing your hair some people can't do
their hair I'm actually really not good
at doing my hair your hair always looks
good I'm good at doing my hair uh on a
remote podcast like don't the hair
that's behind me that nobody sees we
don't talk about herir La if only you
could see the back of my head right now
I'm like I need to make sure that back
hair stays in the back and also like the
headphones allow us to a myriad of
mistakes because I just have to like
keep it behind my ears and then you
don't see you just don't see anything
the headphones allow us to cover up a
multitude of sins yes I love that phrase
add that phrase to the list of phrases
we want to start using mtit multitude of
sins it's like so Grandma I love it let
me look at phrases good terms and
phrases yeah I feel like I haven't been
using the phrases I said I wanted to
start using no you haven't but there's
time we podcast every day yeah the call
is coming from inside the house we all
have a role to play in the war to come
is the blank in the room with us right
now yeah I've Gotten Good at that one I
um you have I still like it's my phrase
I added it to the list and I can't
figure out how to use it I used it
really well the other day in the group
chat I forget about what but I did yeah
you you were being shady always I'm
gonna my goal for the rest of the
episode is I'm gonna I'm gonna find a
way to use that phrase during this
episode okay use it well okay so anyways
Taylor is a billionaire how do you feel
um it feels like
delayed it's crazy that like she's so
successful like really being a musician
is not that like not as lucrative as you
would think considering like how hard
she's had to work to become a
billionaire and from the second she
started making money she's been
incredibly wise it's not like she went
through a period where she went broke
that happens to a lot of people from day
one she has invested she has you know
bought real estate she's been smart
she's done everything right she's been
the biggest pop star for so many years
and she's still now becoming a
billionaire I think it's so crazy
because I read an article that Selena
Gomez is also going to become a
billionaire this year from rare Beauty
and that's just the difference in rare
Beauty has been around what for like two
three
years yeah that's insane that is insane
it but also like Taylor really doesn't
have a commercial
product no and I but I actually think in
the long run that will suit her how
people just like she's not so
um like promotionally you know yeah you
have to like you have to eat a lot of
[__] and like do a lot of things when
you're a business owner who's a
celebrity like you have to make Tik toks
and stuff yeah yeah like Taylor doesn't
have to do that yeah and I think that
stuff does like chip away at your image
slowly over time to make Tik toks right
mhm well I'm happy I'm happy for her me
too I know that these Milestones mean a
lot to her I mean I think that would
mean a lot to anyone for sure to become
a billionaire I hope she's out
celebrating with Trav uh maybe she was
out celebrating last night she was out
in New York I was not dressed nor alert
she went to Holiday Bar a restaurant I
have been to and frequent you know I
could have been
there um I've never heard of it it does
have anything to do with the
holidays uh I think they opened during
the holidays and I thought it was like a
popup for the holidays but then it just
became a restaurant that's like open all
the time it reminds me of her house
Holiday House quietly on that hill Oh my
God it was
totally Easter egg Easter egg
CED C codia I would love a billion
dollars let's keep podcasting Claude yep
the to Jersy are there any billionaire
podcasters that we can even aspire to be
well there probably aren't podcasters
there probably aren't billionaires who
became billionaires from their podcast
but there might be a podcaster who
happens to also be a billionaire yes
agreed with that but like I guess the
most successful podcaster from
podcasting is Joe Rogan and he's got
hundreds of millions yeah like I think
like 180 I thought well I they said that
his Spotify deal was 100 million but
I've been hearing over the years it's
actually far more than that I agree it
was kind of like universally accepted as
100 even though the number was never
released and now like as you know more
time goes on it's being reported that it
was actually more than that like maybe
it was 100 million per year maybe it was
100 million before ads because when I
listen to his show he has tons of ads
yeah but I think the whole point in of
Spotify paying all that money to Joe
Rogan is that Spotify keeps all the ad
Revenue no it's that all the listeners
have to download Spotify and that's
millions of listeners yeah yeah yeah I
wish you would just be honest like how
much you make even though I'm like not a
fan of um PID transparency there's like
this trend on Tik Tok where like you
have to share how much you make I don't
I don't subscribe to that no I just like
I want him to tell me but I don't feel
like he need he owes the whole world
like his pay stub oh yeah no I I'll find
out for me not for everyone yeah yeah um
congrats taylored congrats
congrats our next story Kylie Jenner
matches her faux leather luks with
Kendall and haly Bieber for her Kai
launch amid some Kai drama as well so
there is a designer named Betsy Johnson
not to be confused with you know the
Splitsville Queen The Who splits Betsy
and her
splitz Betsy Johnson that's who we're
talking about no it's not Betsy Johnson
and the
splits wait
Betsy Johnson the blonde I think she's
Jewish designer who us to make like B
Mitzvah dresses who does splits on the
runway this is not who we're talking
about oh my God I read the story and I
just assumed it was her it is not her it
is a different designer called Betsy
Johnson and she's much more like if you
look at her Instagram it's like much
more like Kylie style leather Etc so
Betsy Johnson is accusing Kylie of
thievery even though Betsy Johnson stole
Betsy Johnson's name yeah but what if
she was born Betsy Johnson no I'm
kidding I'm kidding yeah but anyways
yeah she posted a series of Instagram
stories Wednesday claiming that she
emailed Kylie's team Concepts language
and line sheets from her own label
called products and that they went on to
utilize her ideas without giving her
proper credit as a creative director
stylist and consultant Betsy Johnson the
second has worked with Brands including
second including Louis davier and
Balenciaga incidentally she's also
worked with Kanye on a number of
projects including his Yeezy Gap
engineered by Balenciaga line so she's
like probably not unfamiliar to Kylie
I'm sure Kylie's heard of her but when
you see the two things that are being
compared like to me they're not the same
let me look let me
look like they're long leather jackets
but like the leather jacket has been
around like no one she didn't invent the
leather jacket Lea let me tell you how
when I thought this was Betsy Johnson
the way that the the Betsy Johnson of
this story posted on Instagram mad about
um the the new Kai brand using curse
words I'm like I cannot believe Bessie
Johnson talks like this I thought it was
the the older lady it's not it's bie
Johnson the
second um I just want to say
that it's a similar Vibe for sure but
like Vibes are Vibes and we're all
vibing they are leather f two faux
leather
trenches yeah I mean if there we need
she's obviously like in the business of
sharing so if she worked with Kylie and
there's proof like show the receipts cuz
like I I could see you know World in
which this would happen but I'm going to
need a little bit more proof no but like
I could go to farfetch and search
leather trench and I'll see a million
leather trenches like that's not a
proprietary idea also the things about
Betsy Johnson's trench that are very
unique are the collar the shoulders and
the um
asymmetrical yeah it's not really a
trench it's more of like a cape no but
it's the color of the shoulder and the
asymmetrical zip uh closing and Kylie
has none of those things okay maybe it
has a little bit of big shoulders but
it's it's got collar like a flap collar
I will say one thing that gives this
Bessie Johnson legitimacy is that she's
worked with Kylie so she's like clearly
in yeah Kylie I'm sure like knows her
stuff and likes her stuff and it is it
not inspired by her but I don't think
this is like copy paste I don't by the
way it's certainly not copy paste the
jackets couldn't be more different and
the concept of a leather jacket isn't
entirely unique it's very on Trend right
now right yeah that's true so anyways
Kylie had an event to celebrate her new
fashion brand and everone wore some of
the new Styles and they looked wonderful
doing so but it also helps like when
everyone's a model and they're wearing
your clothes how's it going to look bad
I guess it's like a really good reason
to start a fashion brand if all of your
friends are modelesque yeah also Kylie
did an interview with um Wall Street W
Journal where she explained like what
Kai is going to be and it's going to be
like a series of capsule collections in
collaboration with other designers yeah
so this is their first drop is in uh
collab with another designer um it's
that's a unique idea I don't know how
much we need this like for real yeah I
do I like the looks and so far nothing's
more than $200 like it's not it's still
not like a bad idea but then I don't
love the idea of it's like
collaborations with other designers cuz
in some collections I met might not like
some I might like it might not have like
a distinct POV but the business model of
like doing drops is so Kylie like think
back in the day with the lip kits that
really built her whole business so I
think the model is smart I just don't
know I just don't know like I don't know
clothes is really hard yeah and and not
everyone can wear what Kylie wears like
for a number of reasons it's yeah it's
very avangard it's very fashion it's not
like to wear like I have to go to work
like right no I'm a mother right like
I'm going to the supermarket right right
so it's a little nutty but Le jacket is
not these looks aren't nutty I think
haly and Kendall look great in the
outfits I thought Kylie looked great
last night like I like drop one okay
we'll take a drop by drop we're going to
go drop by drop a drop in the ocean a
change in the weather like when I was in
the seventh grade that song changed my
life
tell us more Ron Pope are you familiar
yeah I was thinking that you and me
might ends up together were you
listening to it while looking at
Maverick through the window on the
playground yes through the window pain
and when I think of that song symbolic
of your pain when I look through the
wind when I listen to that song now as
an adult like I I'm brought back to that
moment and that
pain and how do you channel that
pain with my
music
that's actually like what interviews
sound like sometimes I know and let's do
like a mock moronic interview give me a
questions so when you're brought back to
that place how do you Channel how you're
feeling I think that's what's so great
about being a creative and an artist is
that it's an outlet for self-expression
and I think my fans feel that come
through in my music and so if you could
talk to your fans what would you
say I would want them to know that they
are beautiful
and this this relationship we have is so
special because we see that beauty in
one another and my concerts are a
representation of that beauty and it's
really beautiful I love my fans it's
beautiful tury L thank you like
everybody says nothing all the time we
are the generation who says nothing yeah
no word salad yummy yummy word salad
yummy yummy
literally
that's good I like that the way like
that reference is just I act I would
like to see The Wiggles sit down for an
interview and answer for their crimes
about how fruit salad yummy yummy change
the musical landscape
forever word
salad yummy
yummy and by the way hot take fruit
salad is disgusting you shouldn't mix
fruits fruit shouldn't touch fellow
fruits that aren't their own elk ja is
the yumminess in the room with
us I agree fruit salads are not yummy
the like mixing of
juices keep
separate 100% hash keep fruits separate
agreed hash down with fruit salad nummy
nummy not yummy not yummy agreed our
next story Chris Jenner says it was a
huge mistake cheating on Kardashian
senior I saw this she said it was her
life's biggest regret during Thursday's
episode of the Kardashians Chris opened
up to Chloe about cheating on her father
Robert Kardashian senior with soccer
player turned animator Todd Waterman in
1989 and why she felt it was her life's
biggest regret the Revelation occurred
as the two were chatting about Khloe's
ex Tristan and Khloe asked her mom what
was your mindset when you cheated when
you did that with my dad and you had
four kids and you had a family yes I
know you were really young and she
responded explaining that being really
young and dumb is something that plays
into it because you don't really
understand the consequences of your
actions Chloe still wasn't fully
understanding and asked her mom again
but what what was my dad not doing that
made you want to look elsewhere Chris
said I don't know because he was such a
great husband and such a great dad and I
think that I fell into a situation where
I thought that the grass was greener
somewhere else and I made a huge mistake
that's my life's biggest regret so I
actually saw this clip and I thought
Chris was really genuine actually and
the way she described it being like
nothing was wrong I just wondered I feel
like that happens like you just look at
other people and you wonder if the grass
is greener and you feel like it's going
to be harmless and the fact that she
like still looks back on it is like one
of the biggest regrets and he was such a
good husband and such a good dad and of
course the fact that he's dead now and
you always like memorialize people in
such a more positive light I feel like
that's probably something that haunts
her yeah well it's nice that she could
be open about that but I guess like for
Chloe it's like sad Chloe asking that
question like what was he not doing like
cuz that's how she feels like what what
could I what could I be doing to make
him stop cheating
yeah yeah but some people and I don't
think this is true for Chris but I think
it's probably true for Kristen some
people are just
unable to be loyal did I say Kristen
yeah I met Tristan Tristan and Chris
like I don't think that was the case for
Chris I don't think Chris Was a Serial
cheater she like made a mistake and had
an affair and she like can see that now
but with Tristan it's like different
people different moments in time it's
like he's almost unable to be monogamous
yeah I know it's like Chris did that and
then she didn't do it again cuz you like
learn from your mistakes and you
recognize how you feel you don't want to
feel that way again but like he keeps
doing it right so it's not the same but
I feel like Chris like never talks about
this I I want to say I almost didn't
even know that she cheated on him I
didn't know for a fact that she did I
thought it was kind of like rumor swirly
but this Todd Waterman guy like I feel
like he's even been on the show in some
way like Chris met up with him once yeah
because he was an athlete turned what
animator yeah and I feel like remember
when Chris was managing Caitlyn before
Caitlyn transitioned as like a
motivational speaker former athlete and
she was like doing that type of
management for athletes yeah why you
think she did that for Todd I think
maybe he was on the
episode under that guys interesting it
just that's something in my brain how I
remember but it's entirely possible I
feel like I remember it as like Chris's
old boyfriend but not his her Mister
Chris's old boyfriend yeah and they like
go and play tennis together and it was
an outdoor activity yeah the girls
followed her I don't know about about
that but we also could be just confusing
with Todd cranes we could always be
confusing with Todd cranes who's been
really quiet recently I wonder if he's
just like grinding maybe he's just like
living his life I don't know I feel like
you know he's grinding it out and what
he does in the dark will show in the
light yeah no I'd definitely be
interested to see what Todd Crane's take
on the Middle East conflict is 1,000% I
feel like he has his head screwed on
right but you never know you never know
you'd be surprised you'd be surprised
look at these college kids nuts nuts
they are if I was a college student
right now like I think I'd probably drop
out I would drop out and depending on
what I wanted to do that would dictate
whether or not I needed to go back cuz
like for a lot of jobs you really don't
need a college degree and a lot of the
people who are hiring for jobs are like
looking at these colleges and they're
not you know they were sending
applications so maybe you could find a
job but if you wanted to be a
professional that needs a degree like a
lawyer or a doctor I guess I would go to
a
school we need like Jewish universities
honestly but what's crazy like
brise no yiva University oh yeah
brandise is also not a Jewish school
everyone who goes there is Jewish but
it's not the curriculum is in jewi like
I've seen there's incidents of
anti-Semitism at brandise imagine being
an anti-semite and going to brandise
like are you okay did you get lost Louis
J brandise like he was a Jew yeah no the
the school is so Jewish yeah it's a
school that's not curriculum based
Judaism but I I didn't even know that
students who weren't Jewish went there I
mean it's open to everyone but
it's like it's Jewish but there are
Jewish Ben went to a Jewish University
Yeshiva University yeah no but they need
like secular Jewish universities where
it's like okay I'm not here to stud
Torah but so there are if you wanted to
go to a um law school or med school that
is Jewish yiv University has cordoza Law
School which is actually like one of the
best law schools in the country I don't
actually think you have to be Jewish to
go there um they do have uh Albert
Einstein Medical I think they have
medical school okay are there any other
universities other than yeshi University
no I think it's the only Jewish College
we're going to need more yeah yeah no I
would I would not I would not give these
institutions my money who can't even
like condemn what's happening can't
protect but we'll do it for any other
cause like all of a sudden we don't take
a stands right right right right right
50 Grand a semester 50 Grand a year bye
it's it's become more clear I think to
most Jews like on all spectrums right
now from reform all the way up that Jews
aren't in included in activism that's
become abundantly clear Jews aren't
included in
progressivism right and that's just
become abundantly clear especially to a
lot of progressive Jews and it's like
people having this identity crisis
because you know you so much of your
identity is like standing up for others
and then it's your turn and nobody
stands for you so I think it's like a a
lot of Jews are having an identity
crisis right now
yeah but yeah if I was at College uh bye
bye I want my money back yeah no I
demand a refund I I feel like this's
going to be like a lawsuit or something
yeah they're working on a class action
lawsuit if you actually are a college
student and you have experienced
anti-Semitism on campus there is a class
action lawsuit being put together
um and I'll find the information for
where you can sign up cool cool oh now
there's a class action lawsuit I kind of
wish I was a college no I'm kidding no
never never our next story some
Harmony Fifth fourth fourmy fourth story
Harmony okay fourth Harmony Nicola Pelt
is paying tribute to her mother-in-law
as she wears Victoria Beckham t-shirt so
Nichol oh a t-shirt Nicola and Victoria
have been good recently good good they
were at dinner the other night in Miami
like a girly like there was two pictures
like the girl side of the table and like
Nicol and Victoria were next to each
other with I think Victoria's friends
and Brooklyn and David were there and
now Nicola is wearing Victoria on her
shirt like considering there was Cold
War yeah so she's not wearing a shirt
designed by Victoria Beckham it's a
shirt that has a picture of Victoria
Beckham yeah like um it says like Posh
like it's like Spice Girls T-shirt oh M
ailia I like that so Nicola is a Posh
Spice fan on Thursday the actress paid a
sweet tribute to her mother-in-law by
Dawning a retro t-shirt of the fashion
designer from her Spice Girls days she
shared the image of herself with the
caption London
Times London times or London London I
thought you said they were in Miami that
was a different incident oh oh okay okay
so she didn't wear the shirt like twice
in one week There's been
warm cont maybe there was like a family
meeting there was a thawing they have
come to
terms tabular Asad and I love this
because this whole wedding and the now
like in-law situation should be more
iconic like it's so fabulous especially
with the beckhams so in the news right
now and maybe Nicola's like oh maybe my
in-laws like are cool maybe I should
start being nice yeah yeah I think
things got like really bad for a while I
feel like Brooklyn was even talking to
his family but clearly like tensions
have thought the ice scens have come
together for an amazing ice sculpture
but the thing is in the documentary what
my take away from it wasn't really about
Victoria but we got a lot of Victoria is
that she's really not in ice cream no
right so she obviously has that image
because she wears like big sunglasses
and she's like you know like a mean
skinny British lady yeah but like on a
personal level she seems actually very
warm and funny yeah agree and I feel
like when there was first tensions after
the wedding I probably felt like oh it
must be hard to have like Victoria
Beckham as your mother-in-law like she's
the ice queen um and even though we've
also heard you know not the kindest
things about Nicola you could understand
but now I'm like no she's just a mom and
she loves her kids she gives mom energy
and I'm glad everyone is starting to
like see each other yeah cuz it's it
should be like so honic like
billionaires and billionaires getting
together you know who's going to pay for
the boat it doesn't even matter like
that should be fun you know yeah
yeah like let's get out of our own way
shall we yeah so that's a bit of good
news that is good and now are you ready
for our fifth and final story I am
random real estate news okay the
historic flat iron building will be
converted into
condos the the flat iron oh my God what
is it now office building I don't know I
kind of thought it just sat there but I
know I feel like it's kind of it's
iconic you guys definitely know the
building it's just in every movie it's
like an iconic it's and it's also it
became I feel like so big like from
Instagram like people are obsessed with
it on Instagram I feel like also like
bendel's like was always making like
[__] with that building on it you know
yeah it's the building that's like
really thin at one side it's like a
triangle triangle and while it's iconic
architecturally I feel like on the
inside it's literally
practical what the [__] do you put in
that corner a
bathroom okay that's what I think but
yeah I'm curious to see what the
developer is going to do right now it is
office spaces but it will be converted
into luxury housing the impending change
was announced by its owners on Thursday
it'll take about 3 years to transform
the space I mean it'll be sick if it's
like you know it's probably going to be
like some of the most expensive
apartments in the city cuz it's in this
iconic building and I'm sure they'll
make it really nice and people will buy
it just to buy it not to live there like
you know rich people princes are always
like buy like the plaza foreigners yeah
so they buy it as Investments I'm sure
it'll sell really well but I don't think
it's like a practical living space we'll
see what they do with the place but
that's yeah like kind of trippy to like
live in a triangle yeah that like I I
feel like I wonder if the units are
going to be the whole floor cuz it's
like not fair if someone gets the half
of the floor that has PE thin it's thin
yeah no that's interesting
yeah it's also a great location but is
it a great location because it's a great
building no it's a great location it's
not like the heart of flat iron I know
but I feel like all those things like
kind of popped up around that building
because it's the building so now finally
the building itself will be worthy you
know it's going to be really pricey yeah
even though it's like
moronic I'm sure that they'll be able to
engineer to be very cool maybe not even
a toilet like a closet I don't know a
closet like a a nice woman's closet not
a not a broom closet even though it's
kind of the perfect place for a broom
closet it's perfect place for a studio
lard is perf should we bu and then that
would be our
view behind us it's not Windows yes it
is the the peak is Windows the peak is
Windows oh okay that's actually sick I
take it back yeah so if you're like
sitting on the toilet looking out the
window gu no it it should be a part of
the living room even though that makes
no goddamn
sense I mean everyone has a corner in
there like living room it's just a
corner nobody puts baby in a corner good
luck to these Architects who's going to
have to figure it out why did they build
this building like this I'm sure there's
uh you know a historical fact as to why
it's built that way you know what I'm
going to find out what that fact is wow
she's on a mission While You Usher us
into to the next season of this episode
so we're about to do deer toasters our
weekly advice segment but before we do
let me let you know that today's episode
and deer toasters are brought to you by
sax.com we are always doing our best
when it comes to looking fabulous on the
podcast but sometimes our pajama
uniforms and sweatshirts need a little
bit bit of an upgrade and that's why we
love shopping at saks.com for everything
from podcast luks to gno outfits and
more sax is just an institution every
New Yorker knows I feel like every
person knows it's the place to shop but
their website is fabulous they just have
so much inventory you will find what
you're looking for whether you're
shopping for day night you're shopping
for business you're going to a
conference you're going on vacation I
love shopping on the website because
it's so easy to filter they have great
categories and filters that you can look
so if you're going on vacation you just
press vacation feel like you know during
certain times of year they have like a
holiday edit they have Festival edit so
whatever you're looking for you'll be
able to find really easily they also get
like a little nuts with the with the
filtering they get really specific you
know you want to shop by your star sign
because I am a Cancer and Leo moon
rising um you can do that too sax.com is
super fun and easy to shop on so whe
whether you're looking for a cozy Vibe a
more elevated look they've really got it
all at sax.com you can find the perfect
Revenge dress from Brands like
Christopher esber and cult Gaia it's
also a great platform for just
discovering new designers that you can
become obsessed with I feel like they're
really they have their pulse on the
trigger of what's cool and new and hot
and fashion so you can be on Trend
before everyone else is discover new
ways to shop for everything every day at
sax.com that's spelled saks.com their
customer service is amazing I love their
shipping it's just so efficient sax.com
thank you for sponsoring today's episode
today's episode is also brought to you
by carow their internet famous kitchen
wear is a staple for any home and it
comes in a variety of modern Shades to
fit with any design aesthetic Caraway
home's non-toxic kitchen wear features a
chemical-free ceramic coating so food
can be prepared with peace of mind that
no hard to pronounce chemicals will Lee
into your healthy ingredients
introducing caroway stainless steel
cookware set now which is their most
popular product redesigned in the
stainless steel to take your meals to
the next level so I as you guys know
just moved I can't stop talking about it
and I also like donated and got rid of
so much stuff in my entire apartment by
my kitchen specifically and I will say
literally the the only things I kept
were from caroway they just age really
well you can use them for many years
they're made really well they're of
course Al also non-toxic they're also
easy cooking so the Ceramics naturally
slick surface means that minimal butter
or oil is required for easy cleaning and
it's well- loved over 50,000 people have
raved about their Caraway kitchen wear
now it's time to try it for yourself
visit carway home.com theeast to take
advantage of our limited time offer of
10% off your next purchase this deal is
exclusive just for toasters so visit
Caraway home.com theeast or just use
code the toast at check out carway is
spelled c a r a w a y home.com theeast
they have a ton of different color
options different colorways so whatever
the aesthetic of your kitchen is I'm
actually thinking of maybe getting a few
more carway products as my last kitchen
was kind of dark my new one is like
gorgeous with natural light and I feel
like the carway can really shine if I
get like a more bright color you'll see
the addiction of carway I just want
every color carway it's non-toxic
cookware made Modern you know what else
is brought to you by carway what my beef
stew tonight o I'm I'm I've been
plotting my beef stew I have the recipe
pulled up I've been checking it out
while you've been talking did you find
the reason for the flat iron building I
did I found a couple interesting facts I
want to share one it's shaped
triangularly to maximize the building's
footprint on the Triangular parcel of
land okay so that's so the the land so
that's that the Project's structural
engineer named coryon
pie oh my God coryon py L filed plans
for 20 story story building in August of
1901 the flat iron building was not the
first building of its triangular ground
plan although it was the largest at the
time of its completion earlier buildings
with a similar shape include a
triangular Roman temple built on a
similarly constricted site in the city
of Britannia so it goes back to the
Roman Empire and that's why people are
always always thinking about the Roman
Empire they passed something like the
flat iron building the Romans invented
this structural Mar love and we have a
deer toasters today that is my Roman
Empire let's get into it so deer
toasters is our weekly advice segment we
usually do it on Wednesdays I don't want
to talk about it and if you want to
submit we have two ways to submit it's
all Anonymous don't worry you can write
in about anything from family stuff
wedding stuff boyfriend stuff
relationship it's dear toasters
gmail.com that is the email you can
write a submission to we also have a
submission box on our website the toast
podcast .c again totally Anonymous this
one is the first one it's very short and
it's very sweet dear toasters I'm 12 and
I'm wondering when is a good time to get
a
boyfriend it's a really good
question I feel like if you're asking
it's because maybe like some of your
friends have boyfriends and you're
wondering like oh are we ready for this
are we doing this and I just want to let
you know there's never a right or a
wrong time to have a boyfriend it's
natural 12 is really young so don't be
rushed I would say most people have
their first like real boyfriend in like
the beginning of college no there's like
high school there were those people who
had like boyfriend some I said most
people yeah I feel like I feel like when
you're in middle school like you have a
boyfriend but then you guys just like
text and you don't talk well for us it
was on AIM but then like we saw each
other in the halls I don't know oh my
God if you saw your a booyfriend in the
hall back in the day like seriously I
have to transfer schools it's
humiliating the way like your aim
boyfriend literally didn't exist in real
life was insane insane and then you
would break up over aim and things could
go back to normal no honestly like
having an aim boyfriend was so stressful
I feel like we were all holding our
breath until we just broke up with our
aim boyfriend via aim via aim but like
it just meant that you couldn't talk to
this person in school why every but
everyone else was talking about the fact
that you were boyfriend and girlfriend
right and it was just so awkward and I
felt like that phenomenon of my aim
boyfriend ignoring me and vice versa was
only happening to me like no noad it's a
universal experience I'm glad to know
cuz I just I felt like the way I
remember it is like when other people
had a boyfriend that they had from Aim
like they would be a boyfriend on the
playground but like they weren't and I
feel like probably modern day aim
boyfriend is like a snap boyfriend right
or texting texting yeah so I just want
to say like there's literally no rush
and I can't believe a 12-year-old
listens to our podcast you are amazing
and you're going to grow up to be such a
beautiful stunning and smart woman and
there's no rush to getting a boyfriend
like for real yeah some people don't
don't even have their first boyfriend
till they're like 30 and you know what
those people are totally fine and
healthy like don't worry about it yeah
it's it's personal boyfriends are more
personal than comedy but I feel like if
you don't have a boyfriend in high
school there were only a few people at
least at our high school that like were
in actual relationships where it's like
yeah you know we go places together and
we talk to each other in the hallways
right but I feel like you could wait I
don't think at 12 you don't need a
boyfriend friend just like focus on the
things that make you happy it's very
focus on your studies your
extracurriculars your friends you know
learning more about yourself your family
and if we have any other 12-year-olds
listening to the show let me impart a
little bit of wisdom that I
think people probably tell you all the
time and you don't listen but let me
tell you you will get older and you will
wish you listened be nicer to your
parents okay they love you they do
everything for you they're just trying
their best they're also just people just
like you like you struggle with stuff
sometimes they struggle just be nice to
your parents and if any of your friends
tell your parents to shut up tell them
that they shouldn't do that that's true
also be nice to
yourself like you're doing your best
you're so cute the things that you think
are embarrassing are not not and the
things that you think right now are like
going to melt your world and you will
literally not even remember in a month's
time yeah just like go easy on yourself
I used to stress out about the most
random but like tiniest things that now
I just like I almost wish I told someone
about what was stressing me out so they
could tell me like girl you're fine
you're fine calm down so all of those
things that are stressing you out Let It
Go release it yeah and it's Friday
weekend slumber party okay ready for our
next one yeah hey swirly girlies I am
dating uh my Pam of a boyfriend for a
year now and he is perfect in every way
he's a huge sports fan talks about
sports
constantly even has his own football
podcast just like us is this about us
oh my is this play about us yes very
good my senior year of college I entered
on and off into a relationship with an
athlete at my school let's call him Theo
he and I stayed in touch up until I met
my current boyfriend well Theo was
recently drafted to the NFL and my
boyfriend is obsessed with him he brings
up Theo constantly sends me his
Instagram posts his tweets showing me
his highlights I've never told my
boyfriend about Theo because it's in the
past and I'm not sure how he would feel
while I have no feelings for Theo it's
weird to hear my boyfriend constantly
Rave about my ex-boyfriend and I know if
the roles were reversed I would want to
know would you girls tell your husbands
in a situation like this or just let it
be I would tell one cuz he's going to it
it depends on the man like you have to
know your man like yeah you would tell
Zack I would tell Ben he would think
it's so cool right I think this guy
would think it's so cool especially if
like if there what is he like as a
boyfriend is he very jealous is he very
possessive but like okay only a true
crazy person could be jealous of someone
that you dated before you ever met them
and if he's a true crazy person like you
shouldn't be with him oh actually by the
way Jackie speaking facts don't listen
to me listen to Jack so like if he is a
the a good guy and the right guy for you
he will only enjoy this fun fact and
then also like he might think twice
before sending you all this stuff
because he doesn't want to like you know
awaken that desire for you so he should
know that every time he sends you like
Theo stuff that like you know this man
yeah I I also think like your boyfriend
might be impressed by you 100% And you
like you know at any stage of a
relationship Mar you you should always
be like you know wanting your partner to
think fondly of you yeah and I think it
might like make your boyfriend like put
some respect on your name yeah look what
I pulled I pulled a Theo what did you do
no and it's like I better act right or
she could go back to
Theo right right scare him into
submission you tell him shout her from
the rooftops sh yeah you should
definitely tell him because if anything
like most likely he'll just be excited
about it and it'll be something you guys
can talk about yeah totally and if
you're happy and you're not like you're
in a healthy relationship it really
shouldn't matter yeah no and if he takes
it badly then like there's something
wrong with him and you should know that
red flag alert like actually it's
enormously helpful yeah all right our
third and final hey girlies I'm a new
toaster absolutely loving you too I have
not missed an episode so my husband
likes to golf and I try to be a
supportive wife who lets him enjoy his
Hobbies the other day he went golfing
and I decided to send him a cute little
nude photo hoping to spice things up in
the bedroom when he got home I took the
picture on on Snapchat and added a
caption that said here's your prize if
you shoot under 80 I guess that's like a
good score anyway guess your husband's
always posting that over under 80 he's
always posting over under 90 cuz he
[__]
stinks anyway I sent it and his response
was doesn't look like I'll be shooting
under 80 today and that's all he said he
didn't say anything about my body or me
looking sexy or anything having to do
with me sending him this nude photo sure
he was in the middle of golfing but like
you could take two seconds to send
something back I'm feeling a little bit
a little upset about this and I'm not
sure if I'm right for feeling this way
like dude acknowledge the nude does my
husband deserve a grilling for this or
should I ignore the fact that he ignored
my nude okay that's not where I thought
this was going to go I thought it was
going to be like you know his foone was
projected onto the TV oh oh you know
what perspective is everything no but
this is actually like kind of like
making kind of worse and like that's
that's rough that would upset me too
like it's like a feeling of rejection
especially if you're not someone who
like sends a lot of like nudes and puts
yourself out there like that which I
feel like that's the case otherwise he
would know how to respond and you
wouldn't you know I so that's really a
bummer I would mention it the perfect
word Jackie it's a bummer yeah I would
mention it and be like I I was my
feelings were hurt like I yeah what's
worse than like putting yourself out
there like making an advance yeah and
this it's not like risky cuz you guys
are married like you know he likes you
like so you put yourself out there just
to not even be turned down but to be
ignored it's almost worse it would
really hurt my feelings and I would just
say something things so one he knows why
he's never getting one ever again right
and two like maybe he has a reason as to
why like maybe maybe the guys Wii wasad
over his shoulder and he just like had
to respond something like sometimes with
Snapchat if you don't have a lot of
service like the photo won't populate
but the caption will so maybe he just
saw your caption probably not but maybe
he has his CH yeah he is your husband
you should talk this through but this is
why golf is toxic and that's what I've
been saying for years you're like too
good for this world that not only did he
leave you to go play golf but but he
also got nudes right no because the only
thing Ben gets when he leaves to play
golf is an attitude an attitude and
maybe that's how it should be because
they don't appreciate right and he
doesn't even bring back a snack or
anything from the [__] like I love a
country club God forbid he just invites
me like go sit and have lunch like I'll
play and then like no
never do you ever make it known that you
would be open to such a thing no cuz I'm
like a monster because Ben really wants
to join like a club and be a member and
he's like you could swim and like yeah
sure for one month a year and then I'm
like stuck paying for this country club
that just you're using throughout the
year to go golfing and he's like so when
he golfs he golfs with other people at
their Club so he can't be bringing his
wife you know got it so you're kind of
like getting in your own way yeah cuz
he's like let's join let's you could do
you join as like a under 30 you get a
good membership he's like we're a family
we can you know and he's like let's do
it but I'm like I'm against it because
it's golf you should join and it would
be more than one month you really would
have from like May till September
to do your things and in the winter you
could lunch ladies who lunch maybe I
really should you
should okay I'll think about it and they
probably have pickle
ball oh my God what are you doing tur I
don't know and I just missed the summer
stupid tury stupid tury stupid tury all
right we did it we did everything we set
out to accomplish today Fast Five fruit
salad yummy yummy deer toasters real
house SI of Beverly Hill we can send you
guys off into the weekend feeling good
we can thank you so much for your
support your time your
generosity your generosity thank you so
much for listening to the test M show we
Del the fast epis I'm so hungry have a
great weekend everyone love you bye
bye